salut aujourd'hui je suis avec le lac
d'uby ni l'intro soualaise et comme j'ai
eu la chance de la rencontrer sur un
plateau on a fait un plateau ensemble
pour mademoiselle exactement comme et ça
c'était juste formidable de se
rencontrer qu'il est gentil il ya
quelques temps je vous avais fait la
vidéo numéro deux sur le col de reading
et on a beaucoup discuté ensemble dans
les commentaires du fait que
effectivement il fallait pas se fier à
une seule chose il fallait prendre en
compte une base line pour interpréter
les choses c'est à dire que c'est pas
une poignée de main qui va nous dire qui
est la personne
il faut prendre en compte tout le
contexte qui est la personne comment
aller etc et je me suis aperçu qu'on
retrouvait sa aussi dans plein de
domaines y compris dans la musique petit
lien avec le la du bruit puisque en
parlant avec eux là on s'est marré sur
un truc avec quatre accords on pouvait
avoir plein d'interprétation possible
qu'un de chansons possibles
vrai ou faux vrai qu'on peut avoir plein
d'interprétation et d'interprète est ce
que tu pourrais nous prouver ça oui et
est ce que tu pourrais en même temps
pour moi et pour ceux qui regardent la
chaîne m'apprendre à jouer des accords
bien évidemment à l'ordre ses réserves
tout comme tu mentalise les gens je peux
je peux te montrer je peux te mentaliser
sur l'allumé devoir oui moraliser
doivent ce que ça je voulais pas dit
mais c'est où vous mettrez un lien à la
fin on en reparlera mais lola à la une
chaîne qui est vraiment fun vraiment
cool et en même temps tu donnes des
conseils sur la musique et tu nous
apprend des trucs à la guitare j'essaye
et des trucs qu'on n'avait pas appris
encore ah ouais je n'avais jamais vu ça
dans mon bref qu'on vous aura en parle à
la fin mai mais voilà elle transmet son
savoir
parce que mine grave c'est ça m'apprend
la petite mais je suis trop mignon
quatre accords qu'on va pouvoir tourner
en boucle ce qu'il a vraiment changé ça
va être la manière dont on va les jouer
donc la manière j'entends pas les
accords mais j'entends plutôt le rythme
d'accord c'est en fonction des rythmes
là tu vas pouvoir te retrouver
l'interprétation originale donc le
premier accord c'est un moule alors je
place les deux doigts
sur la deuxième case donc pas sur la
corde du premier record d'allied world
deuxième case troisième corde troisième
cas zeller et staline
après on va sûrement dos 2e qu'au 3e
casse
comme ça
troisième corde deuxième case
je vous fasse bien voir ça je ferme et
donc quatrième corps de camp david
café ou encore david c'est bon c'est bon
seul
seul je sais faire je sais le faire le
sol je vous le fais voir premier record
troisième case deuxième et en deuxième
case vide but vide et sixième corps 3e
cat on va sur un vrai
d'accord la petite fille anglais le
triangle puis do sol après
voilà avec ces quatre accords là on peut
avoir on va voir plein de chansons de
possibles et imaginables et c'est
surtout il y en a qui m'ont dit ouais
mais c'est pas exactement les vrais
accords alors oui et non en fait c'est
juste que ces accords là ensemble font
le nous donne l'impression que c'est la
même chanson
c'est ce que je sais faire de mieux les
cta novembre
oh
ah oui [ __ ] je cherche moi journée
c'est pour ça mais je trouve que j'en
fasse il d'ailleurs vous en avez en
commentaires qu'on a pas ailleurs
j'étais dans mon commentaire alors la
première ça va être pas dedans litres
qu'on fait c'est qu'on va faire un
rythme un peu plus rock donc on va
prendre la paume de sa main on va la
tuer mais voilà comme ça pour redonner
en effet tant petrella donc là on est
tous dans le show rock sans le feu soit
youtube
ça y est
m
elliott
d1
ou même
wen dernière en fait voilà pourquoi j'ai
voulu faire cette vidéo avec le lacet
juste pour vivre moi ce mot cranberries
zombies donc là on la joue d'une manière
un peu feutré très calme et là on va
jouer notre chanson qui n'a strictement
rien à voir donc là je vous donne les
chansons qui ont le plus fin qui hurle
le moment à voir ensemble les le groupe
areva c'est drôle
n'existait pas et passer
à côté
ça
c'est lui
il en a
je n'avais pas vraiment
ces deux chansons là n'ont rien à ce
rôle et pourtant tu peux les mettre
ensemble ce qui donne d'ailleurs souvent
on a eu une mode tu sais tu connais les
séries glee
je crois que j'en ai trouvé une wii a
sonné la série glee oui eh ben ils ont
appuyé ont amené un peu dans l'air du
temps ce qu'on appelle les mash up web
et les mails et c'est vraiment le qui
ont ramené ça dans la culture dans la
culture courante et donc c'est assez
récent en finale et c'est pour ça
maintenant que tu vois beaucoup de
vidéos avec des medleys c'est entre
autres grâce à glee donc voilà oui j'en
ai trouvé une j'en ai trouvé mais je
t'en prie trucs biens récents à wim par
contre que je chante pour le dire mais
je sais je sais même pas non j'ai
cherché des champs talich n'apportez pas
elle est tombée
comment ça marche pas mal à l'aise
donc là on est quand même sur des
chansons qui sont dans un style
complètement différent d'un bug qui
n'ont pas du tout les mêmes intentions
partie de trois cultures qui sont
constatés commencer par comme brise
ballack romery c'est vraiment du rock
groupe hyper mythique non pas sur khaled
qui appareille chabon voilà fait c'est
la vie la la la la la la
voilà et du coup sur coup qui dingler
avec ne les laisse pas tomber années 80
et je te fais rare et jamais je veux
juste
en formant
un peu
m
moi
mais oui c'est l'image
bye
généralement on a beaucoup critiqué
christophe maé parce que je sais pas
c'est entendu un petit peu cette affaire
c'est michael gregorio qui est un
imitateur et humoriste c'est un super
jour des faits voilà en fait il a il a
fait pendant trois minutes
un medley donc de toutes les chansons de
christophe maé sur les mêmes accords ce
gros j'avais d'ailleurs ce que je suis
en train de vous donner la wii 2
comprennent tout du plagiat mais je mets
tous que tu peux jouer beaucoup de
chansons que les hommes mais qu'est ce
que c'est
je te dis en fait c'est tout dans la
même veine
santé
tu fais
m
j'ai juste passé une bonne nuit et sur
de carlos santana là quand même
voilà on peut souligner nous voilà donc
tu peux faire longueur avec l'allemagne
perd pas pleurer les guitares je vais
pleurer là viewer moi j'ai une vraie
question est ce que tu te souviens de
cette chanson parce que je suis à peu
près la seule à mon souvenir chameaux
que j'avoue ça faisait petit que petit
au surplus tous c'est petit
au rappeur
août et m
hamon
d'ailleurs j'ai la vue
m
j'ai abordé bon je vais d'amel dans la
chanson parce qu'une partie de l'aimf
ces partis étaient tous en vie
oui toi ah ouais ouais je t'ai pris
départ car c'est là où tu es le plus
envie de donner de toi si vous voulez
vous mettre à la guitare je trouve c'est
une super motivation de ces tierces bon
je commence par apprendre quelques
accords et je peux jouer plein de
chansons avec passé d'ailleurs les
quatre accords les plus simples à
réaliser lietaer parce que parce qu'ils
ne pouvoir
si vous êtes autour du feu avec vos
potes balancer les accords voilà avec
les même si vous êtes au milieu d'une
rue avec des pneus qui brûlent bull
semblait évident sur une guitare
voilà non pas pour alimenter le feu mais
pour alimenter les chanter j'ai à
l'église
c'est drôle je n'avais même pas pensé à
ça pour la vidéo mais c'est vrai c'est
hyper motivant je trouve pour vous pour
vous puissiez à prendre quatre accords
et de se dire qu'à voir la vidéo avec
lola et ça me donne plein d'idées de
chansons déjà je peux faire c'est en
fait c'est moi c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé la guitare c'est en province si
vous avez envie de commencer la guitare
prenait des chansons qui vous font
kiffer et qui sont atteignables ou
parents que c'est qu'être d'accord là
vous avez tellement de chansons possible
que vous êtes sûr trop notre but est
d'être motivés du coup trop démotivation
et dans le même site à désaccord genre
là une erreur
c'est
ce désaccord hyper sympa par le fac qui
en paraît mais que tu peux aussi faire
aussi bien
on accorde désormais plus basiques tu
peux trouver à eaubonne
oui
la cci
eh ouais
situé en fait ces amours là si tu les
fais peut-être dans un ordre différent
oui c'est ça en plus cclat pour
l'instant que tu as fait pour l'instant
du même nom mais en plus si on les
recours déplacé dans un autre ordre
sur les apports que jean de montrer à
tout le coeur gros
bah
à
en changeant l'ordre ouais tu peux faire
c'est fini tu fais là
do
sol femmes
tu as changé l'ordre mais pardon c'est
toujours la même sa part et concernant
la voix ouais parce que en fait j'ai
j'ai pas été équipés à table est équipée
de bonnes cordes vocales
voilà donc qu'est ce que t'as quoi toi
tu as un auto tune ici ouais
effectivement fait j'ai acheté un pro
tools j'ai acheté un bien se rallonger
les parents ils m'ont dit tiens et le
lait ce que tu veux en bonus une voix tu
peut-être que ça peut me servir à parler
que comme moi j'écoute et je pense que
c'est fake ne veulent pas de quoi même
mais merci beaucoup lula de rien avec
les mrc décida corps comme sa jetée sur
le vif n'hésitez pas à adé d'ailleurs
non si vous trouvez d'autres chansons
n'hésitez pas à nous en remettre il en
existe des milliers de possibles avec
104 accord pour faire un vrai lien avec
la chaîne parce que vous dites oui ok
nous doit parler aux débuts de cold
riding pourra préfère la musique avec
lola du billy pas tout à fait faux mais
c'est aussi pour moi une très très belle
image pour vous dire quand vous avez un
site d'interprétation pour du non verbal
comme du col de reading ne vous fiez
jamais à une seule chose parce qu'en
fait elle peut être interprétée de mille
manières différentes et c'est ce qu'on a
vu avec ses guitares là je trouve que je
suis un génie d'avoir pensé à ce lien
mais je pense que c'est mignon
fabien êtes le nom guinée chalet c'est
mais moi j'ai pleuré quand je l'écris il
ya des larmes de sang par contre dommage
mais ça c'est parce que tu avais chanté
avant tout à fait monsieur entendu enfin
en plus je suis sûr que tu vas y chante
bien mais je chante pas faux il chante
juste mes parents c'est très agaçant
comme le camp je chante à je pense que
je mets beaucoup trop d'intention méduse
est la plus belle la plus mauvaise
chanteront chansons chantées avec les
meilleures intentions du monde les plus
belles chances
c'est beau ce que tu dis et c'est comme
ça que nous allons nous marier avec le
la du midi
merci d'être venus chez moi en ramenant
son lit et temps des colons urbaine et
ben écoute salle est grande mais bien 5
du coup il ya quelqu'un qui m'attend pas
d'ailleurs si vous entendez du brut de
l'heure ce qui klaxonnent parce qu'il
fait bon bah on va redescendre en bref
si vous ne connaissez pas la chaîne de
l'aula du mini et bien je ne vous plains
pas au contraire je vous dis c'est cool
parce que vous allez pouvoir avoir le
plaisir de la découvrir comment moi j'ai
déjà découvert en cliquant sur le petit
lien qui est il faut toujours un verset
donc qui est ici voilà regardez là vous
pouvez cliquer et dans quelques secondes
je vais mentaliser lola est ici je vais
la mentalité chez elle sur ma chaîne il
s'attache à natoye direct mais je suis
trop contente lui de film sur ma chaîne
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si
elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à nous
faire savoir nous laissant lola est à
moi un petit léger mais forcément
gracieux et mélodique poussant lane
vous pouvez nous laisser un commentaire
évidemment je les dirai tous et je
sélectionnerais les meilleurs pour les
envoyer par texto à lola et et ont
vaincu moi j'irai me dire si je reviens
sur je l'aï rejet répondre si vous avez
des questions par rapport aux accords
les positions doivent citer que ces
termes vous ne lisez pas les mettre en
commentaire parce que j'aime bien je
réponds pas mais moi aussi j'aime bien
moi j'adore enfin c'est cool n'oubliez
pas également de vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir pourquoi parce
que le mental bugs et une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez vous demain à
17h ciao
m